[Musique]
salut floriane sur le banc ça va très
bien vous avez vous êtes presque raccord
avec notre canapé d'âge là c'est la
couleur de la vie la couleur du bonheur
[Musique]
oui m'enfin
à quoi ça sert un enfant franchement à
vous de me le dire cela mais si cette
jeune chasseur
sinon je peut vous être utile sur cette
chanson
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je l'interprète original de cette
chanson je pleurais j'avais les larmes
aux yeux parce que j'ai toujours eue le
voit et d'un coup il est là devant moi
c'est matt pokora a quand même et on
était tous les trois chantiers je pense
celles qui
[Musique]
atteint mais je leur ai dit oui c'est
manuel match trop marrant bonjour
monsieur le premier ministre vous aimez
l'art contemporain mais mon père était
un artiste et il exposé un peu plus loin
donc de ma présence de manuel valls
il a fait un portrait de son fils ryan
or quand même je n'aime pas la droite je
la mets prix jeu l'exècre dans son
arrogance dans sa médiocrité
mais alors la gauche laïque quasiment un
peu plus pourquoi elle veut nous faire
penser comme ils veulent c'est-à-dire ce
monsieur de bordeaux si on n'est pas
d'accord être le sympa on et göring mois
gély le fascisme je me sens assez loin
du ring
vous en êtes où politiquement alors que
je suis pas autiste à mark rutte et vous
n'êtes pas le seul ça ferait un peu
vieux schnock aux vieilles nomme de dire
c'était mieux avant les hommes
politiques et les femmes politiques
étaient meilleurs non on fait avec ce
qu'on a
voilà il ya peut-être moins de grandes
gueules ya peut-être moins de gens quand
vision de la société et des dix ans à
venir
mais honnêtement il est des gens très
intéressants aujourd'hui au gouvernement
dans l'opposition il faut aller chercher
un petit peu tout ça ceci est à vitesse
réelle exceptionnellement ça n'a pas été
filmée à l'assemblée nationale non ça a
été filmé dans son milieu naturel
[Applaudissements]
coupet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un jour j'avais un ami qui travaille à
tf1 que jamais beaucoup et il me
racontait les conseils de rédaction et
un jour les gens ont dit moi j'aimerais
bien faire un programme là dessus l'hôte
a dit ce serait pas mal d'aller au
cambodge et y en a un caddie rika zaraï
a fait un livre sur les hémorroïdes et
je vous jure que la réponse a été ces
riches en promesses on prend c'est une
piqûre de rappel pour toi oublier qu'on
est dans koh lanta c'est une compétition
et qu'à la base en a signé pour pour un
chien excusez-moi l'expression mais à la
base on est venu pour ça
avec elle tuera le console avec moi tu
jouais avec mon corps demain demain tu
te maries à la de l'argent a dit jolie
elle a toutes les qualités bonbons mon
seul défaut à ses doutes ses mii parce
que c'est un mec qui va se marier
c'est un mec qui va se marier si me
tirer un petit coup avant le mariage
alors temps de voir la maîtresse et dit
je me marie mais je t'en mets très bien
petit olivier abel mois sans hésiter
c'est la faux je me suis inscrit sur un
site de rencontre où et par curiosité
c'est vrai qu'elle est là comme curieux
pour moi la jalousie c'est un manque de
confiance en soi ou une blessure encore
mais c'est pas parce qu'un mec t'as
tromper ne tromperont tous n'oublie
jamais qu'un arbre qui est un mec secret
de bruit qu'une forêt qui avait dit à
jour c'est pas la taille du chien qui
fait la bagarre
la bagarre la télé chien j'ai la chance
que tout est plein mais séparé très loin
les uns des autres
je les fais à l'opéra de monaco
c'est bizarre on n'entend plus de
réaction comme si tu faisais l'amour et
qu'une famille qu'au lieu d'entendre
restes remontent à plus que dans cette
course à la 5g ce qui est clair jean
mathieu pernin c'est que aujourd'hui la
france n'est pas en avance par rapport à
ses concurrents est bon puisque la
france bat en europe
c'est une d un des derniers pays où on
peut pas regarder des films pornos doha
censeurs c'est alors ça c'est la fameuse
phrase d'eric yonne maire de grenoble
anti 5g là est prononcée cet été 1 voilà
pour dire qu'ils ne voyaient pas
tellement l'intérêt de cette nouvelle
technologie puisque voilà elle pouvait
empêcher de regarder de visionner des
longs métrages classés x on élévateur
c'est une belle historique et dans
l'hystérie il ya souvent une fragilité
un travail final mais on peut imaginer
que après
son veuvage et les joue au violon tout
seul et qu'elle ait pris du plaisir avec
son bouton de rose très certainement en
tout cas je le crois maintenant ricard
de nilda j'ai pas envie de non plus les
incriminer totalement donc pour
l'instant je vais analyser je vais
observer et à deux via ce qui vaut pour
le neuf dont le dise simple stupid
stupide sept points de plus 24 il y a
tellement de choses que la fourmi
pourraient nous apprendre comme la
persévérance être entêté et c'est la
fourmi elle même est tout simplement
vraiment incroyable incroyable par son
adaptation sa capacité à manger à peu
près tout ce qui se trouve sur terre et
enfin sa rapidité d'évolution dans le
milieu dans lequel elle évolue
on n'est pas bien là paisible à la
fraîche décontracté du gland
si on pouvais moi je viendrai vous
prendre dans mes bras voilier pour faire
un petit câlin dre non non non merci non
non ça ira ça ira ça nous arrange bien
garde ta boule à neige féraud combien
d'années dans la brume passé à voir le
monde à travers les lunettes du système
savez-vous qu aucun animal n'est
naturellement hypermétropes que
l'anagramme de lunettes afflelou et
foule flatulences avouez que c'est
troublant c'est troubler aussi mais bon
j'arrive quand même à lire l'essentiel à
savoir les articles dans je sais par
avance qu'il conforte mon opinion des
centaines de tweets des heures de
discussion pourquoi pour savoir comment
une girafe devrait porter un noeud
papillon en haut ou en bas du coup c'est
un de ces débats absurdes dont internet
a le secret chacun campe sur ses
positions
même si certains estiment que l'animal
devrait emporter plusieurs ou bien un
seul mais plus grands ouvrez les yeux
bon sens briser vos chaînes méfiez-vous
du net
le vrai monde est flou